ja ich habe ein ganz anderes thema
mitgebracht aber eines was glaube ich
viele menschen in unserem land sehr sehr
bewegt das sind die steigenden
energiepreise die explodierenden
energiepreise deutschland ist jetzt
schon europameister bei diesen preisen
und die ampel tut viel zu wenig das
ganze ist eine entwicklung die über
jahre zugelassen worden ist aber es muss
endlich gehandelt werden denn für viele
menschen wird die energiekosten
abrechnung ein riesenproblem deswegen es
gibt viele vorschläge man kann schon so
nachbarn schauen in polen sind zum
beispiel ist die mehrwertsteuer
reduziert worden für energiekosten an
den tankstellen wäre für deutschland
zumindest zeitweise eine möglichkeit ja
es ist jetzt ein heizkostenzuschuss von
135 euro beschlossen worden aber ehrlich
gesagt wenn man die heime durch zwölf
teilt weiß man dass was das für die
einzelne familie bedeutet und auch die
permanent vor sich hergetragen eine
these die eeg-umlage wird abgeschafft na
hoffentlich ist noch nicht in tüten und
dann zum ersten sieben aber die hälftige
abschaffung zum ersten ersten hat sehr
wenig gebracht also ganz klar hier muss
die ampel handeln denn im wahlkampf
haben sozialdemokraten freie demokraten
und grüne gesagt sie werden die bürger
entlasten so passiert schon beisteuern
faktisch nichts aber bei energie gibt es
eine gewaltige verteuerung und das geld
das geld ist da die
mehrwertsteuereinnahmen sind jetzt viel
höher als vor krone und da muss ein teil
weil bürger wieder ankommen insbesondere
bei denjenigen mit den kleinen einkommen
ich glaube diese herausforderung ist auf
längere zeit eine der größten vor der in
deutschland stehen es muss endlich
gehandelt werden
so sehr herbei ich muss sagen ich bin
verblüfft und erfreut dass ich einem der
prominentesten politiker der linken aus
vollem herzen zustimmen kann und ich
glaube auch im nächsten satz würden sie
nicht zum stimme die reichen werden
immer reicher die mittelklasse bricht
weg und der rest verarmt sowohl das
alles wird angetrieben von einer
ideologischen klimapolitik die wie die
vollkommen gefühllos gegenüber dem
in dem ja der der finanzlage großer
teile unserer bevölkerung ist dass er
okay ich wir sind uns einig dass diese
klimafrage eine der größten
herausforderung ist nur wie man sie
angehen das geht doch nur mit den
menschen und ich komme aus einer region
vorpommern vergleichsweise arm aber vor
allen dingen ist dort zum beispiel das
auto enorm wichtig weil die leute ja es
gibt keinen öffentlichen personen- und
nahverkehr
die alte ölheizung die ist nicht so ohne
weiteres zu ersetzen sind diese leute
haben richtig angst ich kenne das was
vielen gesprächen und das müssen wir
ernst aber es ist nicht richtig ein
elitärer klimaschutz wird scheitern wir
müssen mit den menschen und zwar
weltweit dafür sorgen und deswegen sind
die energiepreise so eine bedrohung weil
die steigerung der energiepreise wird
die akzeptanz für maßnahmen gegen den
klimawandel reduzieren und deswegen muss
gehandelt werden das sind unser aller
interesse
und deswegen verstehe ich auch nicht wie
man über alle möglichen dinge jetzt
nachdenken kann auch haushaltspolitisch
und dieses thema so wenig auf der agenda
hat ein christian linder dann sagt naja
also die eeg-umlage und wir haben ja
schon gehandelt nein ja nicht gehandelt
wann gibt es endlich das konzept was ja
angekündigt war dass die leute was
zurückerhalten und sie haben also mutig
wäre ich gar nicht gewesen hier aber sie
haben völlig recht wir haben eine
situation dass in der krise diejenigen
mit den riesenvermögen die milliardäre
haben ihr vermögen vervielfacht das ist
absurd und dann haben wir mehr menschen
in armut das geht nicht wir müssen
handeln und ich glaube dass da eben das
was die ampel vereinbart hat wir machen
letztlich auch steuerpolitisch im gebiet
faktisch nichts da das die realität im
einkommensteuer bereich gar nichts
kapital überhaupt nichts und der vortrag
den kristallen dazu halt den kenne ich
da ist auch insoweit in ordnung wir
haben im wahlkampf häufig gestritten
aber all die versprechen aus dem
wahlkampf und zwar von allen
entlastungen gesprochen von einer halle
haben von der islamischen woche und es
ist gerade die kleinen und mittleren und
das gegenteil ist der fall so dass
familien sofern zu diese koalition hat
schlecht angefangen ich habe sie für
mich mal die stümper koalition genannt
haben gesehen dass die dass der
wirtschafts und klimaminister habeck in
die bauindustrie ihre eingeschlagen hat
dass die leute gang wussten wie sie ihre
häuser weiter bauen sollen
januar war eine der schlimmsten tage wo
an einem tag entschieden worden ist
förderung ist jetzt schluss so ist für
energetische sanierungen lagen
milliarden anträge wo es auch von
menschen die wenig haben und die darauf
gesetzt habe ich glaube ganz schlimm ich
gehe ob er die wichtigste viel zu wenig
riecht ist die idee in ihrem vortrag ist
die mehrwertsteuersenkung und zwar nicht
nur auf energie sondern es wird ja alles
teurer ihr habt alle alle alle
basismaterialien metall holz alles war
auch lebens mit auch lebensmittel und
insofern ist es ist die zeit gekommen
darüber eine breite diskussion zu führen
ich wollte es in fragen wie stellen sie
sich jetzt mal quantitativ die
meerbuscher senkung vor auf welches
niveau runter gehen na ja gut das ist
wir haben ja in deutschland
mehrwertsteuersätze und da sind die
sieben prozent wären eben genau das
richtige dass man ermäßigten
mehrwertsteuersatz mindestens zeitweise
ob man das dauerhaft auf energie auf
energie ja selbstverständlich und haben
den energiesteuern und das zweite wohl
alles ist die unsoziale sie steuert das
sind mehrwertsteuer gerade das zweite
was ich sage ist der anteil der
steueranteil auch bei energie auch bei
anderen darf nicht über 50 prozent sein
er ist teilweise über 50 prozent das ist
doch absurd da wird klar natürlich die
konzerne verdienen teilweise immer noch
unendliches geld auch da kann und muss
man etwas tun gar keine frage man kann
auch diese zuschüsse machen aber der
kern ist dass wir dort wirklich in einer
hand in ein anderes system müssen im
übrigen das trifft auch lebensmittel das
dürfen wir auch nicht unterschätzen
sagen wir haben die inflation also wir
haben wir sind nicht in das ist jetzt
nicht das ist der neuen regierung nicht
anzulasten das hat sie vielfach geerbt
da es lange zeit viel zu wenig gehandelt
worden ist auch ein europäisches ein
weltweites problem im übrigen hat das
mit der ukraine zu tun von wegen
energiekosten also machen wir beziehen
55 prozent unseres erdgases aus russland
wenn wir mal reden trotzdem zwei redet
ist nicht in betrieb da ändert sich
erstmal gar nichts aber noch zu ihm
einst gibt und es gibt die anderen ein
und wenn dort nichts mehr fließt dann
haben ein problem die amerikaner sind da
ganz anders die haben ihre ehrt bild
importe aus russland
gesteigerten den letzten monaten ich
finde meine bommer wetter werden wie
willich und höhere in deutschland wir
sind da wieder die vorreiter aber die
anderen sehen das so ohne ideologisch
aber das hat mit energiepreisen zu tun
wie viel zum thema zurückkommen das
entscheidende ist in der die offen für
maßnahmen die mehrwertsteuerabsenkung
muss ein punkt der einmal zuschusses ein
punkt es gibt viele weitere die man
wirklich natürlich erneuerbare energien
kann alles eine rolle spielen aber nicht
handeln und zu sagen die eeg-umlage und
ihre absenkung zum ersten juli oder
streichung zum ersten juli löst unser
problem das wird nicht ausreicht sie
haben vorhin gesagt sie hätten das schon
mehrfach artikuliert was sie irgend hier
auch gesagt haben haben sie das im
bundestag schon mal vorgetragen und wie
war die reaktion meinen anderen partei
ich habe das im bundestag vorgetragen
das interessante ist ja dass das jetzt
nicht nur irgendwie ein solitär
vorschlag ist also der bekannte ökonom
bofinger sagt auch das ist eine
möglichkeit wäre die gewerkschaft
unterstützt hat es gibt also nicht
wenige und ich sag nochmal nachbarländer
tun ist einfach sie tun es einfach und
wir machen an dieser stelle nichts weiß
ich das im moment vieles noch an
haushaltsberatung liegt und dass wir
riesige aufgaben haben aber ich glaube
das thema energiepreise wird uns die
nächsten wochen monate und jahre bewegen
das wird das zentrale thema in den
nächsten jahren sein hoffe ich
jedenfalls nicht das ist ein krieg